un amphithéâtre universitaire lieu du
savoir pour débattre de l'avenir du pays
voilà le cadre du grand débat national
commun à montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt
environ 300 participants avec notamment
des propositions différentes autour des
finances et des services publics sur la
dépense publique qu'il faut la réduire
parce que aujourd'hui elle c'est l'aide
à peu près 50 7% du pib et c'est
anormalement élevé déjà déjà le point
lundi sans fort est une bonne chose
les fonctionnaires travaillent dans des
conditions effectivement sur le terrain
ça devient très très compliqué mais par
ailleurs dans leur vie personnelle aussi
ça vient extrêmement compliqué les
quatre thématiques ont animé le débat
avec la participation de quelques jeunes
impliqués notamment sur les questions de
transition écologique
je suis là parce que je pense que c'est
intéressant de s'intéresser à
l'actualité politique et ne pas se
plaindre d'un côté ne pas être entendus
par par les élites et et ne pas venir là
donc je viens pour ça on fait partie
d'une communauté de la cité on a besoin
de voix là de montrer qu'on est là les
jeunes bon c'est vrai que c'est on est
censé être beaucoup d'étudiants ce soir
on voit beaucoup de personnes entre
guillemets mais voilà pour faciliter
l'organisation de cet événement les
villes de montigny le bretonneux et
guyancourt honte oeuvrer en commun lu vs
qu a demandé à alexis constantin
professeur de droit d'orchestrer les
échanges c'est d'animer ce débat
d'essayer de faire émerger les arguments
de chacun les idées les questions les
sentiments mais le tout avec calme
sérénité comme se doit dans un débat au
sein d'une démocratie il ya des
questions qui ont été posées il ya des
réflexions il ya des suggestions
d'organisation de réductions de dépenses
et tout depuis trois mois il ya quand
même énormément de manifestations qui se
sont passé et les gens avaient besoin de
s'exprimer aussi de pouvoir
effectivement dire ce qu'ils avaient sur
le coeur
ce qu'ils souhaitaient comme
modification des propositions aussi
parce que ce soit par exemple ya eu
énormément de propositions
le grand débat national doit se clôturer
le 15 mars prochain une synthèse des
idées doit être réalisée courant avril